encore des marées humaines pour défendre
le climat en nouvelle-zélande en corée
du sud en israël en italie mais aussi en
inde ou au nigeria des millions de voix
qui crient l'urgence d'agir plus de
charbon plus de pétrole
laissez le carbone dans le sol nous
sommes la génération débrouillez vous
avec ça disent ces manifestantes
silencieuse et si son geste isolé il y a
un an est devenue mondiale aujourd'hui
ces mots ont aussi un écho à auteuil ou
comment osez vous comment osez vous
demande la suède natale de greta comment
osez vous voler notre avenir dit cette
pancarte au portugal
quand d'autres détourne le slogan de
donald trump en version beaucoup plus
verte et d'ailleurs les américains un
marché à eux aussi encore une fois
aujourd'hui mais l'épicentre de la
mobilisation mondiale ce vendredi
c'était sans conteste montréal avec ses
centaines de milliers de personnes dans
les roues il si mathieu prost radio
canada
[Musique]